У переважній більшості європейських столиць на дорогах все ще домінує автомобіль.
Однак епідемія коронавірусу спричинила несподіваний побічний ефект:
дала потужний імпульс розвитку велоінфраструктури.
Такі європейські столиці, як Брюссель, Париж, Рим, Берлін та Лондон,
вдалися до "креативу", аби бодай тимчасово реалізувати "зелену" мрію
про велосипед як основний засіб пересування.
І тепер розмірковують над тим, як зберегти цей тренд після пандемії.
До спалаху COVID-19 столиця Бельгії належала до найбільш загазованих європейських міст.
Але через локдаун на вулицях стало значно менше автомобілів та значно більше велосипедів.
До коронавірусу у Брюсселі відносно мало користувалися велотранспортом
через відсутність безпечної інфраструктури. Місту гостро бракувало велосипедних доріжок.
Нещодавно мерія вирішила перетворити 40 кілометрів автомобільних смуг у центрі Брюсселя
на велодоріжки. Зокрема замінити бруківку на асфальтовані доріжки,
зручні для їзди на велосипеді. На чолі "велореформи"
- "міністерка мобільності" Брюсселя Ельке ван ден Брандт, яка представляє Партію зелених.
Вона заявила, що з 2021 року автомобілям у центрі міста
буде дозволено їздити зі швидкістю максимум 30 кілометрів на годину.
Це має підвищити безпеку велосипедистів і дасть їм можливість
стати повноцінними учасниками транспортного руху.
Французи теж у часи карантину, аби зменшити ризик зараження коронавірусом,
здебільшого пересіли з громадського транспорту на велосипеди.
Цей еко-тренд не зник і після послаблення карантину,
а французький уряд усіляко його стимулює. Приміром, на ремонт велосипеда від влади
тепер можна отримати до 50 євро субсидії.
Або пройти безкоштовні курси водіння велосипедом.
Та й сама поїздка стане приємнішою і зручнішою.
Для цього в Парижі після консультацій із відомим велоактивістом
розробили систему нових веломаршрутів із півночі на південь та зі сходу на захід міста.
За вказівкою очільниці Парижа Анн Ідальго, на проїжджій частині
багатьох бульварів намалювали жовтою фарбою тимчасові смуги для велосипедистів,
а знамениту вулицю Ріволі повністю закрили для авто.
Загалом у Парижі й околицях обіцяють створити до 750 км нових постійних велодоріжок.
Саме в Італії, яка дуже сильно постраждала від коронавірусу,
започаткували одну з найбільших в ЄС програм підтримки зеленого транспорту.
Жителям міст із населенням у понад 50 тисяч осіб держава обіцяє при купівлі велосипеда
компенсацію 60% його ціни, максимум 500 євро.
Попит на велосипеди призвів до черг у веломагазинах після зняття карантину.
Приклад нової екологічної свідомості демонструє тримільйонний Рим.
Керівниця міста Вірджинія Раджі дала розпорядження терміново створити
150 кілометрів велодоріжок. Щоправда, екосвідомі римляни
скептичні щодо заяв представниці правого руху "5 зірок", розцінюючи це як популізм.
"Пільгові" умови в терміновому порядку надала велосипедистам мерія Берліна.
Після того, як жителі чотиримільйонного міста пересіли з громадського транспорту на велосипеди,
на багатьох важливих магістралях спочатку в районі Кройцберг,
а потім і в низці інших велосипедистам віддали для руху
одну з автомобільних смуг, потіснивши таким чином машини.
Наразі таких тимчасових доріжок лише 15 кілометрів,
однак не виключають, що тимчасова розмітка згодом стане постійною.
На роботу на велосипедах у Лондоні їздить дуже невеликий відсоток людей.
Це ризиковано і незручно. Однак і у британській столиці нині спостерігається велосипедний бум.
Поки вирувала пандемія, автобуси та велосипеди тимчасово отримали перевагу над автомобілями,
зокрема в Сіті - фінансовому кварталі Лондона.
На окремих вулицях житлових районів проїзд автомобілів узагалі заборонили.
Збільшили також так званий "протизаторний збір".
Його платять ті, хто їде крізь центр Лондона.
Нині він на рівні 15 фунтів стерлінгів із легкового автомобіля на день.
Пожвавився рух на так званих "Cycle Superhighways"- трасах виключно для велосипедів,
які з'явилися в Лондоні за керівництва Бориса Джонсона.
Британський уряд виділив 250 мільйонів фунтів стерлінгів на розбудову інфраструктури,
аби стало більше велосипедистів. Мер Лондона Садік Хан
також оголосив амбітну програму зі створення у місті однієї з найбільших
"зон без автомобілів" серед світових столиць.
У 5 разів має зрости кількість пішоходів, у 10 разів - кількість двоколісного транспорту.
Головні опоненти велосипедистів - лондонські таксисти.
Вони кажуть, що трафік і так жахливий, а велосипедисти лише погіршать тисняву.
Опитування, яке провели у європейських мегаполісах, показало,
що троє з чотирьох громадян хочуть, аби велосипедні пільги,
запроваджені через коронавірус, збереглися на постійній основі.